[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime-doku von
Bild
egal ich hatte Nationalstolz ich dachte
wir zeigen der Welt und Deutschland dass
wir obwohl sie versucht haben uns zu
eliminieren hier sind und in der Lage
sind und der ganzen Welt auf dem
gleichen Niveau wie alle Weltsportler zu
stellen
gegen 5:30 Uhr morgens weckte man mich
und dann sagte mir man hat Moni ein
Sportler in der Delegation ermordet
der israelische Sportler Schau ladani
ein Überlebender des Holocaust erlebt
den Beginn der Olympiade Name als Zeuge
und bringt sich am frühen Morgen des 5
september 1972 in Sicherheit Stunden
später sind alle Geiseln mehrere
Terroristen und ein deutscher
Polizeibeamter Tod wie konnten so viele
Verantwortliche so versagen
hallo und herzlich willkommen zum
zweiten Teil über den Anschlag auf die
Olympischen Sommerspiele 1972 in München
ich bin Toni Haier und wie immer ist mit
mir der wunderbare Mirko Kasimir hallo
Mirko herzlichen Dank für diese
wundervolle Einleitung mein Name ist
Mirko Kasimir hallo bin gleich ganz
verwirrt
am 6 september 1972 schickt Verleger
Axel Springer ein Telegramm an die
israelische Ministerpräsidentin Golda
das grausame Verbrechen in München hat
mich zutiefst erschüttert die
Unfähigkeit sowohl der deutschen
Behörden wie der olympischen Funktionäre
kraftvoll diese schreckliche Situation
zu meistern lässt mich verzweifeln ganz
besonders bin ich entsetzt darüber dass
ein solcher Akt nackten Terrors auf dem
Boden des freien Deutschlands geschehen
konnte in tiefem Schmerz Axel Springer
die Bild-Zeitung schreibt auf dem Titel
16 Tote alle Geiseln als Leichen
gefunden
palästinensische Geiselnehmer hatten im
Olympischen Dorf 11 israelische Sportler
in ihre Gewalt gebracht sie forderten
die Freilassung von mehr als 200
Terroristen sowie der deutschen
raf-verbrecher Andreas Bader und Ulrike
meinhoff die zu dem Zeitpunkt in
Stuttgart Stammheim in haftein saßen den
ganzen Tag über ver diesen Ultimaten bis
schließlich vereinbart wurde die
Terroristen und ihre Geisel nach Ägypten
auszufliegen aber noch während deren
hubschraubertransport zum Flughafen
Fürstenfeldbruck in der Nähe von München
läuft lehnt Kairo den Plan ab bei einer
völlig dilettantischen Befreiungsaktion
sterben alle Geiseln und fünf der
Geiselnehmer
nach Beginn der Terroraktion liefen die
Olympischen Spiele noch stundenlang
weiter nach der Katastrophe von
Fürstenfeldbruck wird aus dem Sportfest
eine Trauerfeier die Namen der Toten
Sportler werden verlesen
Halbfinale
versucht das Grauen einzuordnen für uns
die wir mit festem vertrauen
auf den guten Willen aller Menschen die
Spiele der 20 Olympiade vorbereitet
haben
ist dieser Tag
ein Tag unendlicher Trauer
alles
was ich so schön zu erfüllen schien
ein Fest
das bis gestern so sichtbar die
Sehnsucht der Menschen
nach verstehen Freude und Frieden zum
Ausdruck brachte
ist durch menschliche Schuld ohne
Gleichen in Frage gestellt worden
Bundespräsident Gustav Heinemann gibt
sich kämpferisch die olympische Idee ist
nicht wiederlich wir sind eher stärker
verpflichtet als zuvor
aber keiner dieser Sätze bleibt haften
sondern dieser hier von Avery brandet
dem Chef des Internationalen Olympischen
Komitees
[Musik]
und wir müssen unsere Anstrengungen
klar und ehrenhaft zu bewahren
the games must go on die Spiele müssen
weitergehen wir geben dem Terror nicht
nach wir lassen die Angst nicht regieren
das wollen die Veranstalter damit sagen
aber es bleibt mehr als ein schaler
Beigeschmack Olympia 72 die Spiele aus
dem demokratischen freundlichen
Westdeutschland sind buchstäblich zu
einem Trauerspiel geworden
und die deutschen Sicherheitsbehörden
haben sich bis auf die Knochen blamiert
das hat später immerhin Konsequenzen wie
die Gründung von Anti terror-einheiten
und auch für die Politik in Israel ist
dieses Debakel ein Weckruf
bild-reporterin Antonia Jamin die als
Kind deutsch-israelischer Eltern im Land
aufwuchs also bei diesem Vorfall kam es
ja zu zahllosen sicherheitsmangeln und
am Endeffekt die Art und Weise wie
israelische Delegationen heute in der
Welt gesichert werden aber auch wie
überhaupt
Sportveranstaltungen auf die Welt
gesichert werden völlig verändert haben
heute gibt es keine israelische
Delegation die ins Ausland reist ohne
dass sie gesichert werden und wir reden
über eine mehrschichtliche Sicherheit
also auch eine sichtbare und auch eine
unsichtbare Sicherheit die die ganz
normale Bevölkerung meistens überhaupt
nicht sieht also heute wenn er
israelische Delegation ins Ausland reist
werden schon im Vorfeld Leute hin
geschickt um zu sehen dass der Ort
sicher ist was die gefahren sein könnten
ich würde mal so sagen dass Israel nach
72 erkannt hat dass es sich quasi nur
auf sich selbst verlassen kann und dass
wenn sie ihre Leute sichern will dass
sie es selber machen muss während die
Spiele in München also tatsächlich
weitergehen werden die Leichen der fünf
getöteten Geiselnehmer nach Libyen
überführt dort kommt es zur nächsten
Zumutung für Israel und die Angehörigen
der Opfer die Terroristen erhalten eine
heldenbestattung mit militärischen Ehren
die drei überlebenden Attentäter sollen
dagegen vor Gericht gestellt werden aber
dazu kommt es nicht mehr
Sonntag 29 oktober 1972
Lufthansa Flug 615 von Damaskus über
Beiruts Ankara und München nach
Frankfurt wird entführt die Maschine ist
in Syrien noch ohne Passagiere gestartet
im Libanon steigen die ersten 13
Fluggäste zu eine Viertelstunde später
drohen zwei arabische Passagiere das
Flugzeug zu sprengen sie fordern dass
die Inhaftierten des Olympia Anschlags
aus ihrer deutschen Haft freigelassen
werden in Bonn sind die Eindrücke vom
Olympia Debakel noch frisch die
Politiker entscheiden sich diesmal aber
ziemlich schnell den Forderungen
nachzugeben trotzdem kommt es erstmal
wieder zu einem Nervenkrieg am
Nachmittag werden die drei in
Deutschland Inhaftierten Terroristen zum
Flughafen München Riem transportiert
Lufthansa-Chef Kuhlmann persönlich der
begleitet sie zum geplanten Austausch
der soll damals im jugoslawischen Zagreb
über die Bühne gehen
20 Minuten nach Eintreffen der drei
Terroristen am Flughafen Zagreb landet
dort am frühen Abend auch die entführte
Lufthansa-Maschine die Behörden in Bonn
und Zagreb versuchen eine Salami Taktik
sie verweigern erst den Austausch der
Geiseln und verzögern später das
Betanken der Maschine aber am Ende
gewinnt diesmal das Böse den
Palästinenser werden die Terroristen
übergeben die Geiseln der entführten
Maschine kommt frei in Libyen und
anderen arabischen Ländern gibt es
Siegesfeier den Israelis reicht es sie
verlassen sich nicht mehr auf
irgendwelche Partner im Ausland sie
nehmen nicht nur die eigene Sicherheit
in die Hand sondern auch die Bestrafung
der Terroristen bis Reporterin Antonia
Jamin ordnet ein also nach den
Olympischen Spielen hat halt die
ehemalige Premierministerin goldene Ehre
denn Auftrag dem Chef der Moser mir
gegeben
jeden zu folgen und zu eliminieren der
damals tätig war also jeder Terrorist
der quasi in der Terrororganisation
schwarzer September war und diese
operationshorn Gottes war einzigartig
weil sie sehr lange war also wir reden
über 20 Jahre in den man diese Touristen
in verschiedene Länder europäische
Städte beruht verfolgt hat mit dem Ziel
den zu zeigen egal wie viel Zeit vergeht
und egal wo ihr seid und egal wenn ihr
schon gedacht habt wir haben euch
vergessen wir kriegen euch natürlich
auch heute werden gezielte Tötungen in
Israel verübt im Gazastreifen z.B aber
heute ist der Sinn der Sache anders
heute macht man das um eine zukunftliche
Terroranschlag zu verhindern heute macht
man das weil sie Sicherheitslage so
knapp ist dass wenn man es nicht macht
was Schreckliches passiert diese
operationshorn Gottes war anders weil es
pure Rache war also das war eine pure
Rache die sehr sehr lange gedauert haben
zur operationshorn Gottes gibt
Regierungschefin goldame ihr einen
martialischen Befehl aus ich habe
beschlossen jeden einzelnen von ihnen
aufspüren zu lassen wir werden sie jagen
bis wir jeden Einzelnen zur Strecke
gebracht haben
für die Operation von Gottes wird ein
Team aus Spezialkräften des
Geheimdienstes und der Armee
zusammengestellt erste Aufgabe macht
alle Mitglieder des schwarzen September
ausfindig egal wo sie sich verstecken
insgesamt werden 20 bis 30
palästinensische Terroristen als Ziele
ausgemacht dazu gehören Mitglieder der
Terrororganisation schwarzer September
aber auch Funktionäre der
Dachorganisation der Palästinenser der
plu Bild tv-protokolliert zum 50
jahrestag des Olympia Terrors den
anschließenden Rachefeldzug Israels Rom
1972 der palästinensische dichter und
verherrlicher des schwarzen septembers
weil suitier wird hier am 16 Oktober mit
12 Schüssen aus einer baretta Pistole
getötet
Beirut 1973 hier findet am 9 und 10
April die größte Zorn Gottes Operation
statt 15 Moss hat Agenten drei von ihnen
als Frauen verkleide t gehen mit
Schlauchbooten am Strand des Hotels
Beach an Land und erst stürmen zwei
Häusern bei Rot 1979 hier spürt der
Mossad Ali Hassan Salami ein führungs
Mitglied der Terrororganisation
schwarzer September auf Paris 1992 der
Planer des München terros aktiv bei so
würde am 8 juni vor dem Hotel Meridian
niedergeschossen
die hier geschilderte Serie von
liquidierungen läuft aber nicht ohne
Rückschläge im Sommer 1973 unterläuft
den Agenten ein tragischer Fehler in
Norwegen sollen Sie Ali Hassan Salami
liquidieren den Anführer des schwarzen
September aber sie treffen den
marokkanischen Kellner Ahmet buciki ein
Kundschafter hatte das falsche Ziel
übermittelt Sex Mitglieder des
Killerkommandos vier Männer und zwei
Frauen werden anschließend in Norwegen
festgenommen und zu mehrjährigen
Haftstrafen verurteilt
Ministerpräsidentin goldami ihr
verkündet das Ende der Operation aber
das hält nicht lange ihr Nachfolger
männerchem Beginn lässt den Zorn Gottes
fortführen sechs Jahre später gelingt es
dem mossa doch noch Hassan salami in
Beirut zu töten und zwar mit einer
heftigen Autobombe dabei kommen auch
mehrere unbeteiligte Passanten um
israel hat die Vergeltung also sehr
gründlich in die eigenen Hände genommen
wie man heute sehen kann brachte das im
Nahostkonflikt aber keinen dauerhaften
Schutz aber das kleine Land hat sich in
aller Welt Respekt verschafft
in Deutschland dagegen musste sich
einiges ändern zum Zeitpunkt der
olympischen Tragödie war keine
Spezialgruppe von Scharfschützen
verfügbar geschweige denn eine echte
Anti terror-einheit die Polizisten vor
Ort am olympischen Dorf gaben ihren
Kollegen in Fürstenfeldbruck nicht mal
die korrekte Zahl der Terroristen durch
das Gelände am Flughafen war so
ausgeleuchtet dass die Mörder Deckung
suchen konnten alles in allem eine
Vollkatastrophe als Konsequenz wird am
26 September 1972 die grenzschutztruppe
9 als schlagkräftige Anti terror-einheit
aufgestellt kennen wir heute als
legendäre GSG9 beraten ließen sich die
deutschen Polizei Chefs dabei übrigens
von Leuten die sich mit dem Schutz vor
skrupellosen Terror aus kannten mit
Experten aus Israel
aber die Gründung der GSG 9 markiert
leider kein Ende der terrorgeschichten
die ploutete weiter und in Deutschland
sollte die RAF noch viele Jahre
Unschuldige töten
und damit sind wir am Ende der heutigen
Episode angelangt vielen Dank dass Sie
dabei wart wir haben die Geschichte von
Olympia 72 mit Material aus dem Archiv
des Axel-Springer-Verlages erzählt sowie
Ausschnitten aus der offiziellen
Dokumentation der Spiele Redaktion
Antonia Jamin und Stefan netzebandt
Aufnahme und schnitt Antonia Heier und
die Postproduktion erfolgte wie immer
durch Wake world München bis zur
nächsten Folge eure Toni und euer Mirko